the Trump administration is calling
North Korea a very grave threat but also
says it's ready to negotiate
senators piled into buses yesterday to
attend an unprecedented classified
briefing at the White House House
members were briefed at the Capitol the
u.s. says that its THAAD missile defense
system in South Korea will be
operational in a few days
China North Korea's main ally opposes
that US move the Chinese say they'll
carry out military drills in response
Adriana Diaz is in Beijing with the new
effort to avoid a possible war
adrianna good morning to you good
morning with tensions mounting here in
Asia the Trump administration says it
wants to defuse the situation to try to
bring Pyongyang to the table peacefully
US officials laid out options Wednesday
including ratcheting up diplomatic
pressure harsher sanctions and relisting
the regime as a state sponsor of
terrorism but while a diplomatic
solution is preferred the u.s. Strike
Group deployed to the peninsula is only
a few days away and the Pentagon says it
has military plans ready as a last
option Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
will make a case to further isolate
North Korea diplomatically on Friday at
the UN the UN announced it's sending a
human rights expert for the first time
to North Korea next week the question is
how much she'll actually be allowed to
see Charlie thanks Adriana Diaz in
Beijing